we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p as many of you know i
will sometimes use the phrase if all you
have is a hammer
right if all you have is a hammer we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines no no i don't know that i would
call a hammer a machine i would call it
a tool if all you have is a hammer
everything looks like a nail and if you
are obsessed with vaccine conspiracy
theories
then anytime anything happens to anyone
you point to vaccines our old friend
eric from mass called in
about justin bieber and haley bieber's
recent health troubles
what do you think he blames for them
take a listen
hey david it's eric from math uh
what do you think of that justin bieber
and haley beaver both getting vaccine
injured um
paralysis in the face
um a stroke and a quad to hayley
paralysis of the face for uh bieber it's
all listed there from the vaccines
that's a fact
there's no disputing that
um
oh hey uh good luck with your uh kid on
the way that sounds uh that sounds great
um
too bad you won't have uh the same
income with the site and you'll have to
find another way but if you're a
resourceful guy i'm sure you'll be all
right yep no i'm actually i'm gonna be
doing uh i don't know how many of you
know about barista fire
it's quite a movement and uh i'm really
the the real reason i've had my espresso
machine is i'm gonna i'm gonna be moving
into a second job of making coffee very
very soon okay so listen uh justin
bieber has been diagnosed with something
called ramsey hunt syndrome uh it
happens it's it's basically shingles
based we don't have to go into detail
but it's when a shingles outbreak
shingles is related to um chickenpox
right it's when a shingles outbreak uh
affects the facial nerve okay it has
nothing to do with the vaccine
whatsoever i don't even know if justin
bieber's vaccinated quite frankly haley
bieber justin bieber's wife um did have
a small stroke recently again no idea
whether she's vaccinated and no evidence
whatsoever that it has anything to do
with the vaccine and remember
when all you have is a hammer everything
everything looks like a nail when bob
saget died of blunt force trauma to the
head
candace owens said this is a vaccine
death and
then of course the autopsy came out and
it was not
um sometimes people you know i've told
i've told the story
uh of my
late cousin fabian bielinski a
well-known argentinian
movie director
of nine queens fame and many other great
films when he was in his mid-40s he went
to brazil for a production
and he had a heart attack and died
and sometimes these things happen and if
you want to just blame everything on
vaccines that someone may or may not
have received you certainly can do it
but i prefer to stay in the world of
evidence and reality that's just me you
do you do you
eric from mass on today's bonus show i
will describe to you the insanity of my
last uh eight days on planet earth yeah
it's crazy we will also talk about the
massive dumping of the stock market and
crypto and the bear market and
everything that's going on is a
recession coming you know i don't make
predictions but it's a question people
are asking i don't make predictions i'm
not going to tease that i'm going to
predict on the bonus show oh the bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad i'm not
going to predict that
i'm not going to make any predictions
but i will promise a good time on
today's bonus show sign up at
joinpackman.com
uh take pleasure in my misery that i
will describe to you from the last eight
days of dealing with a newborn
all of that and more when producer pat
joins me on today's bonus show see you
then